bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
sur tv fil 78 pour un nouveau numéro du
7 8 sociétés
le débat de ce soir porte sur le
numérique à l'école
est ce vraiment une révolution de
renseignements vous pouvez réagir
participer posez toutes vos questions à
nos invités sur twitter en tapant
hashtag 7,8 société on attend bien sûr
vos commentaires tablettes tactiles
tableaux numériques interactifs
e-learning visioconférence dans le
primaire et dans le secondaire
est ce que ces technologies apportent un
plus pour les enfants en termes
d'apprentissage
comment enseignants parents et enfants
accueille-t-il ces nouveaux outils
d'ailleurs les enseignants sont ils
formés à leur utilisation
pour tenter de répondre à cette question
eh bien nous avons quatre invités autour
de la table on commence avec irène
pereira qui est enseignante de
philosophie en lice et l'a chargé de
cours en sciences politiques à paris
dauphine vous serez formatrice des
enseignants du primaire à l'université
de créteil à la rentrée prochaine pour
soirée anne perrin notre deuxième invité
jean michel fourgous maire d'elancourt
conseiller départemental des yvelines et
premier vice président de la communauté
d'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
vous avez notamment remis deux rapports
parlementaires sur le numérique à
l'école en 2010 et en 2012
bertrand mesure vous êtes secrétaire
départemental du syndicat d'enseignants
snuipp fsu pour les yvelines et enfin
valérie trauma qui est présidente de la
fédération des parents d'élèves fcpe
dont pour les yvelines
merci à tous d'avoir accepté notre
invitation à venir débattre du numérique
alors en septembre dernier le président
de la république françois hollande
annoncé un plan numérique pour l'école
en déclarant je le cite à la rentrée
2016 tous les élèves de 5e seront
équipés d'une tablette et auront une
formation au numérique mais il faut que
tous les enseignants soient impliqués on
dégagera l'argent nécessaire l'éducation
est une priorité
et d'ailleurs le présent la le président
pardon l'a réaffirmé
plus tard en février dernier il souhaite
je le cite également une grande école du
numérique bon monsieur fort gauche on va
commencer avec vous si vous le voulez
bien
il semble y avoir un consensus en tout
cas sur le numérique aussi bien à droite
qu'à gauche je suppose que vous voyez
cela en tout cas les déclarations de
françois hollande comme une continuité
du travail que vous avez maintenant
temps parlementaire non indiscutablement
il ya un consensus droite gauche sur ce
sujet et c'est plutôt rassurant pour la
performance scolaire de nos enfants
alors justement quels sont les avantages
du numérique pour vous en terme
d'apprentissage ce qu'est ce que ça
apporte concrètement pour les parents
qui ne vous écoute et qui veulent en
savoir un peu plus sur l'école du futur
pour vous qui avez déjà en cours 1
écoutez d'abord
ça les rend beaucoup plus autonome moi
par exemple à juillet en achetant
l'angleterre dans sur des campus
universitaires ou les étudiants me
disais que cueilli la preuve qu'ils
prennent et 80 % de leur temps
d'apprentissage sur sur ordinateur ou
sur la tablette ou sur et que 20% sur la
partie court ou amphithéâtre donc faut
bien veiller à deux mains et on a vu des
études dans la mission parlementaire qui
montre bien qu'un enfant qui est
autonome avec des outils numériques est
beaucoup plus performant notamment
l'université bon donc il est clair que
en développant les compétences vous
améliorez quand même le deuxième mort ça
augmente la le plaisir le haut un enfant
apprend apprend avec beaucoup plus de
plaisir vous augmentez le plaisir
d'apprendre ce qui est formidable
les enseignants entre un tram il
s'exprime autrement
a priori les enseignements qu'on a c'est
que l'enseignant enseignes et plus de
plaisir parce que c'est plus rapide
c'est plus au dnc
il peut échanger avec ses collègues
interactif oui puis en plus il ay là le
hilal eu le retour du regard de l'enfant
qui ont volé un enfant quand un prof est
à l'aise en numérique
tout d'un coup l'enfant ils vont suivre
il est sur mon mac
donc on sent c'est quand même un élément
de valorisation et c'est aussi bien sûr
ça augmente la créativité
alors ça c'est je vous rappelle qu'on
avait on a un problème en france à nos
enfants et la confiance en soi et on a
un problème en france c'est que les
enfants ont peu confiance en eux il ya
des ses disciples mondial là dessus ou
européennes voilà donc ça augmente la
confiance augmente l'autonomie
ça augmente la créativité le plaisir
d'apprendre enfin c'est déjà beaucoup et
en même temps on se rend compte je dis
que quand on est autonome et outils
numériques bien sûr vous apprenez
partout et aujourd'hui on apprend plus
qu'on le veuille ou pas je précise bien
ou mal mais on n'apprend plus à
l'extérieur de l'école qu'à l'école
donc je crois qu'il faut il faut que
l'école voilà se revoit son remette à
plat toutes ces choses là
puis en août +1 modernise la pédagogie
la pédagogie et des gens qui s'ennuient
à l'école moi même quand j'étais jeune
je bon et je dois dire que que de lutter
contre l'ennui à l'école aussi fade ans
dans les banlieues dont on ne sait pas
mettre à bouger quand même pas mal
travaillé sur trappe aussi bas c'est
formidable ce sont des outils sont des
outils qui sont d'une nouvelle
génération aider et vous pourrez vous
ressemblent ailleurs si lisa va annoncer
vouloir installer également du match du
mans on va demander justement aux
enseignants qui sont avec nous à rennes
tejera est également bertrand mesure est
ce que le numérique permet justement de
mieux avoir capté à l'attention des des
enfants que ce soit dans le primaire
dans les collèges ou même pour les plus
grands les études sur la question et
puis mon expérience d'enseignant contre
effectivement que ça permet de de capter
l'attention mais c'est une attention
exogènes donc en fait la tension
exogènes c'est le fait que lorsque vous
regardez un écran vous êtes fasciné en
fait par l'écran après le problème c'est
effectivement est-ce que ça favorise les
apprentissages est ce que c'est un outil
de gestion de classe qui peut être
pratique pour les enseignants mais en
fin de compte est ce que l'enfant va
véritablement apprendre
lorsqu'il est face à ces outils il faut
pas confondre le plaisir subjectif que
ressent l'enfant et ce qui la prend
réellement est là du point de vue des
études scientifiques
on ne peut pas dire que les études
disent de manière enthousiaste que il ya
une vraie différence grâce au numérique
alors dans la mission parlementaire de
jean michel fourgous
il ya plutôt des
du positif qui a été sorti par les
études et vous me dites le contraire
alors bertrand mesure puis après on va
voir on vous demandera qui croire dans
dans tout ça bertrand mesure n'avais
plus de plaisir à enseigner avec le jeu
de plissés enseignants les enseignants
dirais que ça dépend des enseignants un
certain nombre d'entre eux sont
confrontés au quotidien avec la vétusté
des équipements informatiques dans les
écoles et là le plaisir peut vite
tourner au cauchemar quand on sait les
difficultés qu'on peut avoir avec son
ordinateur personnel
moi ce que je dirais c'est que
l'informatique à l'école c'est
obligatoire c'est un outil que les
enfants doivent apprendre à maîtriser
c'est un outil intéressant dans le cadre
d'une pays dans ce qu'on appelle des
pédagogies actives qui permet de
remplacer alors moi j'ai connu l'époque
de l'école freinet où il y avait une
imprimante au fond de la classe
donc les outils informatiques peuvent
prendre le relais de ces outils là il
est de toute façon il faut apprendre à
les maîtriser dans le cadre de
l'éducation à l'école
néanmoins c'est un outil et c'est pas ça
qui fait pour les enseignants le
fondement de l'apprentissage qui fait le
fondement de l'apprentissage c'est
arrivé à maîtriser une notion à les
maîtriser dans le contexte collectif de
la classe et être capable de l'utiliser
de façon décontextualisés est pour vous
le numérique ne répond pas à ça le
numérique est une porte ouverte sur le
monde extérieur
c'est une c'est un outil qui peut être
formidable qui peut permettre
monsieur évoqué tout à l'heure la
créativité
c'est un outil créativité au même titre
que d'autres et donc et c'est un outil
de créativité incontournable
actuellement donc il doit être travaillé
à l'école mais il doit être travaillé
dans de bonnes conditions et
malheureusement on peut saluer l'effort
qui est fait sur les encours par
monsieur le maire mais l'état actuel de
l'équipement informatique des écoles
c'est une catastrophe depuis le plan
informatique pour tous deux
de jean pierre chevènement c'est une
suite de gabegie qui font que l'on
investit des sommes énormes dans les
écoles et qui n'arrive pas à mettre en
place la fonctionnalité que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure c'est à dire l'ouverture
sur le monde et l'outil au service de la
créativité car justement vous parlez de
ce plan informatique pour tous de 1985
si je ne dis pas de bêtises alors est ce
qu'il y avait eu avec ce plan
informatique pour tous des résultats
concrets est-ce que ça avait montré que
les élèves était plus impliqué plus
atterrissez que ça leur permettait
d'avoir un résultat en fait la volonté
politique de l'époque avait été de créer
une filière industrielle autour de la
mise en place de ce plan informatique
pour tous et en fait ça a été l'échec de
cette filière industrielle a signé
l'échec de l'informatique à l'école est
malheureusement trop souvent c'est ça
qui se répète au travers d'aidés effet
d'annonce c'est à dire que si derrière
il n'ya pas les éléments qui permettent
de penser ce que l'informatique peut
apporter à l'école s'il n'y a pas les
éléments qui permettent d'assurer la
maintenance du matériel d'assurer le
fonctionnement quotidien
les logiciels etc j'irais même jusqu'à
dire ce qui permettrait aussi puisqu'on
évoqué la créativité des imprimantes
performante permettant de réaliser des
choses ça n'a pas beaucoup de sens en
gros s'il n'y a pas d'argent ça ne sert
à rien j'aurais l'ordre en ligne un
mouvement large évoqué l'ouverture sur
le monde
la plupart il ya quasiment aucune école
dans le département qu'ils soient dans
lesquelles chaque classe soit câblés et
donc et cette porte ouverte sur le monde
valérie trauma donc je le disais en
introduction vous êtes présidente de la
fcpe pour hbo pour les yvelines alors il
ya des établissements pilotes dans les
yvelines qui testent le numérique dans
les classes que ce soit dans des
primaires ou d'en haut dans deux
collèges
alors quels sont les premiers retours
que vous avez vous du terrain que ce
soit du côté des parents des enfants
également si vous avez aussi des retours
d'enfants et puis et des enseignants
parce qu'on veut lui y'a déjà l'effet
découverte qui plaît énormément parce
que c'est
c'est un produit qui est déjà en fait on
dire utilisé au sein des foyers
et pour ceux qui n'ont pas le plaisir
est utilisé au sein du foyer du coup le
découvre par le biais des
expérimentations qui qui sont mises en
place
en fait nous ce qu'on y voit sur tron
intéresse effectivement le fait que l'on
puisse passer à l'étape du manuel
numérique et non plus du manuel en fait
tel que qu'il était encore utilisé
actuellement puis voilà maintenant c'est
plutôt des succès des projets en fait
sur du court terme c'est pas forcément
du long terme
c'est difficile en fait nous d'avoir une
projection de savoir effectivement si
c'est quelque chose qui apporte vraiment
une plus value ou pas sur le long terme
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que
nous les tablettes en fait elles sont
déjà entrés au sein des foyers
donc les élèves qui utilisent couramment
ce que l'on voit de plus en plus nos
côtés par an c'est la difficulté pour
les élèves de maîtriser en fait leur
image par rapport aux à tous
l'utilisation des comptes facebook et
profils et effectivement ça pose
vraiment problème
donc je pense que c'est plutôt quelque
chose qu'on attend c'est un
accompagnement fait au niveau vraiment
des parcours en fait de deux formations
pour les élèves en fait qui ce vraiment
comprendre en fait comment utiliser ces
médias enfin c'est ce qu'il est parfait
pour l'instant on vient tout doucement
par le biais de la sensibilisation en
fait et parce qu'on est confronté au
problème mais effectivement on n'attend
pas forcément une révolution en terme
d'apprentissage au niveau des classes
mais plus le fait d'accompagner les
enfants sur comment utiliser ces
ressources
alors justement et bien nous sommes
allés sur le terrain pour demander aux
saint quentinois saint-quentinoise ce
qu'il pensait du numérique à l'école et
on écoute et on regarde ce que ça donne
ouais c'est leur génération et peut
autant qu'ils soient qu'ils soient dans
ce fut là quoi moi ça me paraît pas mal
c'est leur génération et
je dirais que voilà pour ceux qui n'ont
pas la chance déjà d'avoir tous les
ordinateurs à la maison ça va leur
permettent de pouvoir s'habituer
toutes ces nouvelles technologies et de
vivre en leur temps oui oui oui de toute
façon on peut pas l'éviter d'une wii oui
bah disons c'est pour les enfants c'est
très ludique
alors moi je suis plutôt pour parce que
je trouve que c'est bien déjà d'éveiller
les allées les gens à ça et puis en plus
c'est enfin y en a quand même partout
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment lourd de
prendre des livres à l'école et tout ça
avec les tableaux interactifs et tout ça
ça permet vraiment de je trouve
d'alléger le poids des cartables et ses
fins et c'est pas négligeable quoi alors
justement comme disait une des personnes
interviewées
il ya un aspect ludique qui est souvent
associé aux tablettes jean michel
fourgous
est ce que aujourd'hui on arrive à faire
justement ce changement est de passer
d'un objet que les enfants considère
peut-être comme un objet de
divertissement un objet un pédagogique
pour apprendre des choses comment ça se
fait concrètement par exemple pour les
locaux non mais il semble de plus en
plus
avancer que que on passe d'une pédagogie
trop frontal en france qu'à évoluer
quand même un peu bon le trou magistral
trop trop vertical à une grasse ce type
d'outil à une pédagogie beaucoup plus
participative un enfant dayraut tableau
ou télé ni et s'exprime bien facilement
il a moins peur des du jeu il peut
effacer si une erreur plus facile mais
enfin bon on voit bien la différence
une pédagogie plus individualisé la
meilleure pédagogie pour lutter contre
l'échec scolaire enfin moi je vous êtes
enseignant depuis puisque moi mais mes
de ce qu'on nous ait dit c'est
effectivement la pédagogie
individualisée oui c'est là où vous
aviez par ball-trap il faut il faut et
on a on a on a on a du travail en un
travail important à faire je pensais et
il faut il faut avec ce genre d'outil
oui indiscutablement vous avez quand
même bien sûr vous changez la pédagogie
en plus bien je vous avez accès est
quand même tout d'abord une rapidité
giroud soyez riche ou pauvre puisque
dans ce pays mais toucheront plus pas
d'égalité alors si vous mettriez vous
que vous allez prendre un truc en or non
ça va ça va pas changer la qualité de
l'image la rapidité du système
alors si vous avez raison les moyens
bien sûr dans les écoles le très haut
débit par exemple on s'aperçoit l
encours vu le niveau de techniques de pi
très important qu'on a on a un problème
de saturation
quand tout le monde se met à toutes les
classes et raillée visioconférence pour
les cours d'anglais avec un prof des
états unis machin à épiler toutes les
tablettes bon et donc on est obligé de
passer au très haut du seuil on passe au
très haut débit mais bien sûr vous avez
raison de poser le problème comme des
moines ya un moment donné alors il ya la
formation des profs aussi parce que idem
pour le pour le fort mais aussi des
élèves à utiliser ces médias ces
nouveaux médias mais mais je dirais que
c'est parti
il faut trouver les moyens guerre je
regrette que l'on n'ait trouvé deux
milliards enfin trouvée obligée de faire
de meilleurs pour les rythmes scolaires
alors que avec 2 milliards on aurait pu
avoir toutes les communes de france
aurait pu avoir un niveau d'équipement
assez proche de celui de l'encours je
regrette ça mais bon en tout cas je
pense que sans ces partis et demain il
oublie une chose c'est que la plus
grande révolution qui a eu lieu dans
l'est dans les dix dernières années et
dans les 30 dernières années même c'est
cette démultiplication de l'intelligence
qu'apporte le le numérique on à
démultiplier la force du bras avec le
marteau à la force des jambes avec le
vélo avec la moto de s'ouvrir mais
aujourd'hui le meilleur démultipliant
l'intelligence c'est quand même le
numérique et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui
voilà il faut le prendre mais c'est le
prof c'est le prof qui est au centre qui
doit dire ce qu'on en fait mais met
d'ailleurs je rappelle que la majorité
aujourd'hui des profs y avait 40% des
profits il ya dix ans qui était pour le
numérique à l'école aujourd'hui c'est
quand même plus de 80 % notamment le
secondaire bon mais je pense que vous
savez vous n'êtes pas non plus un
adversaire farouche bertrand mesure
peut-être le numérique comme disais à
l'instant jamais seul
jean michel fourgous un démultiplicateur
d'intelligence je pense qu'il faut pas
trouvé de la très ce type d'outil parce
que ça reste des outils uniquement des
moyens et c'est tout dépend justement de
l'intelligence qui les utilisent sur
internet vous avez des informations et
non pas des connaissances et on peut
nous parler digital natives mais le
problème c'est que voilà les enfants qui
sont nés après l'ère du numérique
pour autant ça veut pas dire qu'ils sont
capables de me sélectionner
l'information de faire preuve de
davantage d'esprit critique et donc la
formation au numérique
elle doit être orienté vers du fonds et
le fond c'est la formation à l'esprit
critique la formation de l'intelligence
et de ce point de vue là les outils
numériques ne peuvent pas se substituer
à cela et vous pouvez même faire ce type
de formation sans outils numériques qui
est important c'est vraiment la finalité
que vous donnez à votre enseignement
plus que les outils que vous utilisez à
mon avis et pour parler de chiffres est
ce que concrètement dans les écoles où
il ya du numérique est ce qu on a noté
une augmentation des résultats des
élèves est ce qu'il ya quelque chose ou
est ce que c'est
pour et le contre et ya des études de
disposer enfin que je connais qui
avaient ils sont d'ailleurs qui sont
assez ancienne et qui ont été
réactualisés démentent que dans une
classe en grosso modo sur la durée on ne
dépasse pas ce qu'on appelle l'effet m
c'est à dire qui appartient vous avez un
enseignant qui engage et qui met en
place une pédagogie dit ce monsieur qui
n'est pas frontale mais qui vit qui
suscite chez l'élève qui essayent de
solliciter sa subjectivité de mettre en
situation de raisonnement et de
confronter ce raisonnement à celui de
ses camarades de ses pairs et au travers
des des connaissances proposé d'essayer
de construire quelque chose on
s'aperçoit que le résultat est positif
mais parce qu'il ya un engagement qui
est volontaire et voilà alors l'outil
informatique va apporter quelque chose
c'est indéniable c'est l'ouverture sur
le monde avec tous les to les bémols
gueule que j'apporte à toi je leur ai
juste donné un exemple pour vous dire à
quel point on en est l'académie de
versailles ces quatre-vingt-dix mille
personnes ont actuellement le la
messagerie professionnelle dans
l'académie de versailles
c'est 10 mégaoctets par personne comment
voulez vous qu'on arrive assez faible à
faire passer numérique dans les écoles
avec un tel un tel niveau de 2
enfin une messagerie professionnelle
c'est pas 10 mégaoctets
on en n'est pas là alors je parle même
pas des espaces numériques de travail
qui sont extrêmement difficile à mettre
en oeuvre
parce que ça consomme ça consomme des
ressources ça consomme d'énormes
ressources et donc c'est un outil et il
faut que cet outil se développe parce
que c'est nécessaire parce que c'est le
monde d'aujourd'hui
mais il faut pas en oublier pour autant
les finalités qui ne sont pas de
maîtriser l'informatique mais de devenir
citoyen dans ce monde
valérie trauma pour les parents d'élèves
justement est-ce qu'ils ont leurs
regards ce qu'ils ont leur mot à dire
sur l'introduction du numérique
est ce que vous êtes capable ce que vous
serez capable dans les années à venir à
aider vos enfants à faire leurs devoirs
notamment où est ce que je vois aussi
vous falloir une formation dans le
numérique
je ne suis pas maître en fait de
l'évolution que les supports vont
prendre là en tout état de cause
l'école n'a pas tant changé que ça
malgré l'introduction des du numérique
en fait sous forme de tablette
ce qu'on voit sur tous et de
l'utilisation pour des projets en fait
de classe donc on apprend aux enfants à
utiliser des logiciels ou créer des
tutoriels ça c'est quelque chose qu'on
nous demande nous entendons déjà parents
en fait on se forment en fait on
continue à se former tout le monde notre
notre carrière fin de notre parcours de
formation en tant qu'adulte donc on suit
leur buteur en fait en temps par an et
effectivement on voit bien maintenant
avec les intérieurs générationnel avec
les grands parents qui se forment en
fait à l'utilisation des téléphones
portables prennent leurs petits-enfants
donc je pense que c'est des outils en
fait courant et dont je pense qu'on
arrivera à se former ou à suivre en fait
l'évolution fur et à mesure et c'est le
rôle de l'enseignant qui va changer
également puisque j'ai lu dans votre
rapport que vous parliez non pas
d'enseignant mais je vous cite
d'ingénieurs pédagogique est ce que vous
entendez par par cette terminologie
alors ça c'est un grand des mains et
surtout les profs des chansons sont pas
je me faisais quand enfin on sent que ça
il voulu tout bon sens abonde à bord
le prof il est central c'est lui qui qui
met ça en place
et pas question de sortir l'enseignant
de données pour l'afm être pas le talent
en effet m oui mais sur les faits m il
est fondamental il le problème c'est
qu'il est démultipliée avec le numérique
serkan un prof qui je sois dans la
mission n'avait fait parmi une catégorie
une quatre classes on avait classé les
profs en quatre catégories la catégorie
1 c'est celui bon qu un jour un
ordinateur dont 100 plus beaux habits la
catégorie 4 c'était celui qui avait déjà
eu plusieurs générations d'ordinateurs
tablettes tâches annexes
il préparait ses profs avec ses
collègues
donc on y voit la lys et kouriles ça
c'était quand même alors qu'ils sont pas
forcément mais ça c'était pas dans
l'esprit grave au départ bon ensuite il
faut il préparer ses cours aussi avec
les élèves
il était bien sûr ils échangeaient de
façon interactive à domicile aussi donc
là on sentait vraiment puis la façon
d'utiliser les logiciels le lait les
fabriquer lui-même ses ressources face
complète auteur de deux problèmes du
bourrage bien sûr que les ouvrages
scolaires se sont ils vont être
numérisés sont en train de se faire
mousser bien tous les éditeurs s'y
mettent et boissons bon on va là c'est
celui qui était vraiment qu'il
fabriquait ses propres ressources
mutualisées aussi avec les élèves et on
voit envoyé même plus regarder les
lèvres comment un dictionnaire n'était
pas le même nom mais là vous allez lui
faire changer parce que je lis toujours
votre mission dans votre oncle preuve le
rôle du prof
le rôle du prof et centrale c'est un il
démultiplie ses plus values le prof qui
s'approprie complètement cela il
s'aperçoit très vite qu ils
démultiplient salle plus values lui
faire son métier change mais il a
beaucoup plus d'impact et ping
et puis c'est très valorisant pour le
prof bien sûr mais il faut s'y mettre
il ya un moment où il ya eu des moments
de dix ans quand j'ai eu des profits ont
du coup je suis pauvre de boules obut
maire vous que payer des équipements la
pédagogie c'est nous tous là et on a eu
des explications et tous ceux qui se
sont mis à rire et parfois la tête c'est
simple oui mais c'est le début mais
quand il dit qu on compte aussi qu'on
leur dise m'ont volé du matériel et ses
idées et ses mai et maintenant ils se
sont mis à 100% et nike team et est
opposé et aujourd'hui ils sont 100 % et
il n'y a pas d'état d'âme que ces essais
ont alors vous dites quand même l'école
n'a plus pour ronnie crawl la
transmission des savoirs il est
essentiel de redéfinir les compétences à
développer chez les élèves et les
compétences que doivent posséder les on
sait danser un changement totalement du
rôle de l'enseignant un père pour moi
pas vraiment parce que en réalité comme
je voulais dit ce qui reste fondamental
c'est la formation des intelligences de
l'esprit critique la capacité à
apprendre qui est qui doit être lié à
aussi un certain nombre d'acquisitions
de savoirs et les outils numériques
ils ne sont que des outils et de ce fait
comme si je parle de ma pratique
professionnelle je fais il m'arrive de
faire des cours avec du numérique et
pour autant c'est un problème que vous
soulignez vous même le riz c'est au
contraire d'aller vers des pédagogies
beaucoup plus frontale puisqu'on a
tendance à les verts du cours magistral
lorsqu'on fait des présentations et puis
d'autre part lorsqu'il s'agit de faire
deux de la formation à l'esprit critique
je peux le faire sans numérique
c'est-à-dire qu'il m'arrive d'interroger
les élèves sur ce qu'ils ont vu sur
internet etc et de leur demander quelles
sont les méthodes justement de l'esprit
critique les méthodes scientifiques et
sans avoir du tout dit numérique et je
pense que je fais une éducation
numérique est bien plus pertinente par
exemple que lorsque je fais un cours
magistral
voilà deux philosophies et vont me
disais justement en préparant cette
émission est vrai que une heure
d'animation de vidéo par un numérique
équivalait à 15 minutes de lecture c'est
ça pas évident que si vous voulez la
vidéo ou une émission ça va beaucoup
moins vite ça ça n'a rien à voir avec
afrique le numérique c'est l'audiovisuel
mais beaucoup moins performant si vous
voulez dans la danse pour s'informer que
la lecture est la lecture
les études le montrent ça reste quand
même un vecteur très important de niveau
scolaire jusque là le problème c'est que
sur le numérique on lit pas comme sur du
papier c'est pas le problème n'est pas
en soi de numerix église est en fait des
livres sur ordinateur très bien mais le
problème c'est que les élèves ne lisent
pas des livres sur les ordinateurs
voyez s'il lisait des livres sur les
ordinateurs pourquoi pas moi vers 3h
vraiment pour terminer parce qu'on
arrive au wild légion présenter quelque
chose il faut faire aussi très attention
à l'introduction de ces outils chez les
tout petits enfants il ya des processus
de maturation neurologique
neuropsychologiques qui doivent qui
doivent se faire par trois en ce sens
avant 2 avant l'écran serge tisseron a
fait toute une étude là dessus et donc
pas d'écran avant trois ans et pas
d'ordinateur avant 6 ans 6 ans merci à
tous les cadres d'avoir participé à ce
débat la semaine prochaine à la même
heure vous retrouvez wilfrid d'un riggi
pour le 7-8 politique quant à nous on se
retrouve dans 15 jours pour un nouveau 7
8 sociétés à 18h30 en direct bien sûr
n'hésitez pas à vous rendre sur le
twitter de tv fils hashtag 7,8 société
et à poser toutes vos questions
merci à tous les quatre et bonne soirée